on Friday a bunch of middle school and
high school students confronted Dianne
Feinstein at her office to demand she
back the green New Deal we have 12 years
to turn this around well it's not going
to get turned around in ten years what
we can do but for once an adult wasn't
having it Feinstein spoke truth two
toddlers because there's no way to pay
for it I've been doing this for 30 years
I know what I'm doing you come in here
and you say it has to be my way or the
highway
I don't respond to that I've gotten
elected I just ran
I was elected by almost a million vote
plurality and I know what I'm doing
so you know maybe people should listen a
little bit my goodness she's about five
minutes away from telling them to get
out of her yard but what does that
remind you of when feinstein says to the
kids
there's no way to pay for it she sounds
exactly like a republican talking to a
democrat finally the sketcher is on the
other foot now i'm sure some people
thought feinstein was too mean to the
kids who were no doubt parroting slogan
slogans programmed by adults who see the
kids as conduits for the latest
left-wing software but the truth hurts
and if you're gonna use of a kid as a
political shield you put them in the way
of the truth more important if you don't
feel a little gross when you see kids
used as props there's something wrong
with you mind you these kids are pushing
a plan that bans fossil fuels in ten
years do you think in a few years
they'll feel the same way when they get
their learner's permit but don't blame
them it's the parents the teachers the
activists they know that there are
untenable political positions require
propagandized pawns to survive and you
got to get the pawns when they're young
and then hope and pray they don't grow
out of your stupid ideas I am gonna
Jesse I'm gonna start off and say that
this works on both sides I can't stand
kids on the left brats on the right
you'll remember kids I can't say kept
remember Jonathan Crone is that
yeah this kid was all over Fox was just
so good CPAC yeah he was like 13 right
winger he was just they were trying to
interview them you of course you did
they tried to get him on redeye I said
no I go he's not on redeye ever because
I know it's gross because he's a lefty
he's actually a decent reporter he like
goes to Syria he's like oh he's actually
become somewhat of a individual so maybe
these kids are gonna turn out to be
conservative exact just like you just
like Jesse's listen I you know these
kids have bedtimes they shouldn't be
running us industrial policy they can't
even play with the matches you know and
all of a sudden she's supposed to say oh
you're right great point Susie let me go
tell my staff we're gonna die in 12
years
it's funny how she handled it it's kind
of like a grandparent during
Thanksgiving when the grandchild comes
home from college and they start talking
about global warming and the
grandparents like it's freezing we're
going to Naples in two weeks so I think
there's two things going on here one in
on the left when you're wrong you get
promoted
for instance Al Gore said all the polar
icecaps we're gonna melt in 20 by 2014
well they're still there
and what's her name AOC says the world
is going to end in 2030 but I bet we
wake up in 2030 and she's even more
powerful it's called failing up and
what's also happening in the Democratic
Party it's now split into three groups
Greg you have the adults and you have
the children and the adults pretending
to be children in order to win the
election the adults are like the schultz
is and the Feinstein's that know the
thing's a scam the children are like the
aoc and the Bernie's that actually
believe this stuff and then do you have
the adults pretending to be children to
get elected like Booker and Feinstein
they know it can't work but they pander
to these people in order to get votes
yeah yeah let's throw to just one more
piece of tape from that little meeting
this is my favorite part where are the
people who voted you you're supposed to
listen to us that's your how old are you
I'm 16 I didn't vote for me
reality check from diet it's not just
somebody who's had it you didn't vote
for me you're 16 you can't vote are you
one of my illegal voters in California
maybe that was it but just eat kids
can't play with matches least those well
yeah they emit carbon dioxide that's
right actually help you know we are anti
ours I can tell you as a child who won a
recycling art contest and I was like 9
oh my god I can tell you this is all
indoctrination and ast got on her
YouTube or whatever her live feed and
was talking about the world was gonna
end we have to do something about it
which proves that these people believe
in so much government that they think
government is the only response to any
of this we're all gonna die these
predictions have made before in 1970
Paul Elric predicted that 65 million
Americans were just gonna die off as a
result of the environment well that
never happened and so this is an
alternation
it's a leftist group that came into her
office with a special interest project
they used kids to do it and I thought
she reacted pretty well one can I put
you what we've been we've mentioned aoc
I tried like I try to keep our portions
of AOC down to 5% but this is her
talking about like what you should do in
an apocalyptic scenario that we're
facing now the issues gotten worse so I
don't think that working on an issue for
30 years alone is what qualifies as is
what makes someone qualified to solve an
issue so it's basically like there's
scientific consensus that the lives of
children are going to be very difficult
and it does lead I think young people to
have a legitimate question you know
should is it okay to still have children
I agree with her one she's saying all of
her peers don't have kids I'm saying
nobody that cuz the kids just get in my
way one is that right and they emit
greenhouse gas oh sometimes
involuntarily yes
so you know by the way I think that some
of the polar ice caps are melting I
think Greg was trying to save you guys
because things like turning points USA
March like boy a lot of young kids who
are out there and uses the face of that
compare adults why school and college
kids and they don't know I thought
senator Feinstein who I have tremendous
respect for no word like her very much
had an opportunity to engage those young
people now I must say I spoke it off you
know what I said you guys don't vote you
don't give money and that's what the
senator was saying you don't get money
but that's a pretty cynical thing to say
the young people who are becoming
politically engaged who are making a
visit to Washington a visit to their
senator she missed an opportunity she
knew it was a trap but I guess the truck
is then you have a bunch of kids first
talking points you have a grown adult
standing right there this happens all
the time in schools I worked at a school
you have an adult or a moderator or or a
Dean or whatever it is and they want
their agenda push so they hand kids a
bunch of propaganda and then the kids
repeated she knew it if those kids came
to you or to me Jared I yeah I think we
could hold on to our positions that had
been worked through but at the same time
at the same time make those young people
feel special lying to those kids and
Diane why because they're telling them
this is what they can do it's totally
reasonable and she's the only adult
who's actually told them the truth she
says okay if you consider her truth and
feelings are not yes because her truth
agrees with you can feelings and she was
being honest young people those kids
they should be told that it makes a
difference if you I'm putting forth an
important climate legislation but we
can't pay for this she's not she doesn't
want the regional
we're gonna be live in 12 years that's a
bad thing
no that's that sticky back telling your
kids breaks if you don't want it what
kind of parent what kind of parent tells
their child you're gonna be dead it's 12
years that's a great parent everything
to us I might I'll go but I think that
using kids is a way to avoid a real
debate if I put a kid up here in front
of me you have to you end up you don't
give your best foot forward you don't
can't argue with a kid so maybe every
Democrat should bring a child up on to
the debate stand that'd be great had the
child
that'd be hit a second you mean I can't
bring Jesse to work